-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
you know from his work on
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
He's also the host of
"America's Got Talent,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:00 here on NBC.
Here's my conversation
with Terry Crews.
Terry, it's always so lovely
to see you.
I know from every one
of our interactions,
you are the most positive,
optimistic guy.
You can provide a unique
perspective on a lot of things.
But one thing is, you played in
the NFL from '91 to '97.
And I'm wondering
what your reaction was
to Commissioner Roger Goodell
saying last week, basically,
"We got it wrong.
We should do a better job
of listening to our players."
-You know,
it was the same feeling I felt
when I saw Obama's inauguration.
I thought
I would never see this.
This is a --
It was a moment that, you know,
it stands in time,
even to this day --
to watch, you know,
Roger Goodell actually admit
that they were wrong
because, again,
I left the NFL 23 years ago,
and it was -- it was --
it still is, but, you know,
racism was prevalent
all the way throughout.
And, you know, but there was
a lot of indignities
that I had to just put up with
simply because I wanted to,
you know,
make conditions better
for my family.
That's the way it was.
And to see this happen,
and especially --
and one of the big things,
and I have to call, you know,
Roger on this, though,
is the fact that they did not
mention Colin Kaepernick.
-Right.
-Which is still the most glaring
example of racism
that the NFL has ever had,
and they could correct it.
But I'm really, really hoping
that Kaepernick gets a chance
to show himself on a NFL field,
which would really mean healing.
It would really take, you know,
the NFL seriously
on everything
they're saying right now.
-You know, I think a lot of us
watch the NFL,
and we see white players,
and we see black players,
and we think, "Oh, this
is a great example of diversity,
because, obviously,
the league
is a meritocracy,
you would think,
and the best players play.
But can you speak a little
to how black players
were treated differently
than white players
in your years in the league?
-When we were in the locker room
and you were in
the training room,
basically, you had an injury,
it was always viewed,
in regards to the black players,
that we were faking,
that we were trying to
get out of work,
that we were trying to skip the
game and, yet, get paid anyway.
And with the white players,
we noticed this whole thing of
if they were injured,
it was because,
oh, man, you know,
it was a real injury.
It was something that we're
going to get you back from.
But this was a through line
in the league.
You know, another thing that
happened to me in the NFL is --
I had a coach when I was --
My second year in the league,
he decided he wanted
to call me Tyrone.
And this is a white guy.
And I said, "No, sir.
My name is Terry."
He was like, "No, I like Tyrone.
I'm going to call you Tyrone."
And you're talking about this
whole mood of, you know,
even when we were out there,
out on the field,
you know,
they're walking the line.
It felt like a plantation.
And you felt like you
could be bought and sold,
and you actually were.
If a lot of NFL players realized
they could do more, they would.
You know, it's like, "We could
go on and do something else,
because who wants to get knocked
out on Monday Night Football?"
You know what I mean?
But my thing was, is that once
I discovered that
I did have more,
it lost its power, you know?
It was one of those things I was
like, "I can go and I'm fine."
And I think more players
right now realize the power
that they have more than any
other time in NFL history.
Especially, you know,
with the current events
that happened,
you know, just lately,
it's a wake-up call
for the league,
because, again, you are talking
more than 60% of the players
are black, but there are
no black owners,
very few black coaches,
and it still, still
needs to change,
I mean, immediately.
-You were on the Rams in 1992,
during the riots then.
Pulled over by the police then.
-That's right.
-And being a player for
the L.A. Rams
did not provide you
any safety in that.
-Not at all.
In fact, you know, we were in
Orange County at the time,
and I was driving into L.A.
It was after the riots.
And I was pulled over by
a couple cop cars,
which really shocked me.
It was like, "There's two here."
And I was told to put
all four of my windows down,
keep my hands at 10:00 and 2:00,
and those officers
came out of their car
with their guns
pointed right at my head.
I can't even describe
to you how it felt.
I mean, you are so flustered.
You don't know if
you are doing things right
or you are doing things wrong.
They are barking things through
this megaphone about, you know,
"Put your right hand
into your pocket.
Get out your identification,
put it out the window."
You know, just like,
if I make one wrong move,
the whole thing is,
you realize I could die.
If they don't understand
my moves,
if they misconstrue
any move that I am making,
they would feel
justified to shoot.